welcome to our 2022 director's close-up
spirit awards edition i'm just here to
console uh david and rafael for that i
just lost last weekend
what does the rest of your shirt say it
says sigourney
my aunt uh bootleg shirts she sells them
no reservation dog shirts but like
you'll see them everywhere there's
something about making a tv show the way
that images travel in this medium is so
big we tell the story we know it's worth
telling and people come to it in this
art form that you work in the biggest
thing is
you got to get a canvas and you got to
just put the paint you'd be putting
together all this cool [ __ ] you're going
to do all this stuff i'm going to tell
you right now our season one none of
this i i had a horse that would fall on
command in a scene we got to share
resources too you got a number for that
horse they can follow
our show is rejected by four or five
networks i just say never give up uh
never surrender and um that's from
galaxy quest
[Music]
we're in this moment where we get to say
things and show things that have never
been seen before it's about how we go
through the story you're not about you
know what you assume the story is that
the truth is like calling to you from
the beginning
and all you gotta do is get out of the
way